Russ I want to begin with you and this
idea of the seminal spirit because
nomads two worlds i believe is an
ongoing project you've been documenting
this interest of yours and wonder if you
could tell us about the Seminole Tribe
of Florida and what this has to do with
some of your work I've been
collaborating with indigenous cultures
since the year 2000 through Nomad two
worlds and basically I use it as a form
of communication so I will work with an
indigenous culture and through the
photography we sort of explore the
culture and I learned a lot and we try
to find a way to make that relevant and
I met the Seminole Tribe of Florida met
Chief James E Billy a few years ago and
I was just absolutely fascinated by this
story they were numbers were 87,000 and
they were crushed down to just two
hundred people they've made a complete
economic and cultural come back and
that's the story that I wanted to cover
and we started the collaboration the hut
explaining a little bit about how you
got interested in this particular
project with the Seminole a try because
you went to visit them and their history
is they ended up a lot of them in
Oklahoma but the tribe still remains got
4,000 members yeah in Florida yeah well
Russell approached me about it and told
me the whole story told me the history
about it I know Russell you know through
work and we're like family so when he
came to me with this amazing idea about
bringing two worlds together and kind of
showing everybody what amazing obstacles
this tribe has gone through I was just
really honored to be part of it I'm
going to hear more about kind of what
they've been through in the history with
the tribe you talked about how you and
Russell are sort of family because you
work closely together right it does a
family always get along because right
now you've got new york fashion week
right what is the typical you describe
what a typical day is you said you got
up at like half past six today maybe not
a typical time but what what is a
typical day to have to do all this well
a fashion week yeah i mean when i used
to do all the shows it's it's crazy you
get up at six in the morning you go to
hair and makeup you're there for two
hours you rush to a next show you're in
traffic your agents on the phone
you you go to bed at three up and say I
mean it's crazy now I have the luxury to
choose what I want you so I don't ask
you soon so I don't I don't do all every
single show anymore I can kind of pick
and choose so I'm lucky tell people a
little of your history you're originally
from Namibia yes by my dad is from
Namibia I grew up in a little town
called her at 110 which means big
fountain in Afrikaans and my family's
still there it's an amazing place to
grow up and I think that's why this
project really spoke to me too you know
growing up in Africa and being seeing
different cultures and stuff it's very
it's very incredible to kind of open
your mind to different people and what
they what they have done in the world
Russell do you remember the first time
that you got to work with mahaffey I've
tried to scrub it out of my memory you
have all right I sounds like a good
story go ahead we know we I remember
working with be Hardy I think in the
last six years we started to work
together and we've just had a terrific
work relationship I mean when we will be
doing this project which is a called
seminal spirit I was looking for someone
that had what I feel is real spirit they
could carry this because we're not
trying to tell the history of the tribe
that's belongs to the trial what we're
trying to project is an idea of
something forward and progressive and
the hardy occurred to me throughout all
my years what I know about the Heidi is
just she's got an amazing spirit and and
I so my experience of working with
Behati is it is like trying to get
kittens in a basket some good but it's
all over the place working together
we're like joking it's such a fun
environment so I think it always works
out and when we get together do you get
organic or if you do when you get to
look at all the fashion that is
available now particularly this week at
new york fashion week is there something
that stands out in your mind that you've
seen um I love the Alexander Wang Cho I
thought it was really forward and it's
got a lot of chain metal dresses which I
loved very goth punk rock it was very
Marilyn Manson II did you see it yes
I've did it all right okay clearly you
have another favorite in mind
do you have something that I mean you've
been doing this I gotta for a while
right or a veteran at photography in the
fact yes and certainly doesn't make me
an expert of fashion you're talking to
an expert of that is very flip flops
like that I know that yes I'm still
waiting for a designer to cover the
range of flip flops I that Donna Karen
collection was amazing they saw that two
days ago I I'm driven by shapes and
light and the idea of it